all right Michelle
where'd you grow up where are you from
originally
um I grew up uh in Newtown Connecticut
um but I was born on Rota in the
Northern Mariana Islands what is that
close to uh Guam Guam but um they're
further up a little bit
um
I'm Chamorro because a lot of people ask
what's you know what's my race so I'm
Chamorro
and we were adopted me and my sister I
have other siblings but it was just me
and my sister who were adopted
um I was two she was one
so we were adopted by a couple that are
from Newtown
and very known they're very well known
in the town for what he does so
um
I don't remember much up until I was
about seven or eight me and my sister we
started like wondering why
certain things just didn't add up we
didn't celebrate birthdays we didn't
know what to break our we never had a
birthday party but we would go to other
people's birthday and we were like wow
and then we would go to their house the
neighbor's house and we would see their
rooms and their rooms was all like
pretty and and had toys but in our house
there was no sign of kids there was no
toys
um okay can I ask get back up back up a
little bit and ask why did your
biological parents lose you
um my mother had an affair and then I
guess my father found out and didn't
want to be in the relationship anymore
so they went their ways um she ended up
doing things that uh they this is from
what you know she did she suffered um
depression after that
and she put us in a car me and my
siblings and she pretty much just left
us there in the jungle to die
but um someone found us a family member
and my baby brother was full of
mosquitoes he was only like not even a
month old he was a newborn
so after she had him I guess she went
into like a depression but back then
depression wasn't even known or talked
about especially on the islands like
it's so remote
so um that happened so my biological
father knew a couple from the state
and he figured they would be great for
me and my sister to go and at least get
a better education
get out the islands and you know so um
let me see
um
so yeah so that happened we ended up
living there with the with the
adopted parent how was that that was
tough
um she was very abusive physical and
verbal
um she didn't like us at all
we were used as like like they did
something great you know we were just
like a product like like we they didn't
we weren't like
loved at all but um
she abused and then he was more of the
touch type person like like to touch us
um inappropriately yes a lot a lot of
times
um
a lot with me more than my sister my
sister really suffered like more of the
physical abuse
um I got it too but I think I got more
of the other physical touch type thing
and
I started to remember that like around
seven or eight
and I knew
I started getting feelings like wait
something I doesn't I don't like this
this that
and when he started showing me
pornography
it would like bring me downstairs at
night and make me sit there and watch
porn with him and he would get off on
that and then obviously he'd do things
because that was appealing to him
um my sister she was upstairs a lot
um
but like I said she suffered a lot of uh
physical abuse from her from the uh
adopted
woman
um
okay so fast forward
um my sister I was 12 years old so
my sister had went to school one day and
we were she was just sick of the abuse
and she was only 11. so she went to the
school
in Newtown and she told the guidance
counselor that what was going on at home
I happen to be at home playing sick so
he was there on a lunch break
and the police and social worker were
knocking at the door
and
um I just remember the worker telling me
it's okay it's safe
um we're gonna take you somewhere real
quick we just want to make sure you're
okay and I was so confused I was crying
so hard I was crying for him it was
crazy because I'm going down the stairs
and the police have them to the other
room
and I'm looking at him and I'm crying
for him like what's going on save me and
they're actually the authorities are
saving me but I'm looking at him like
you saved me but obviously that was
so uh we got we we were turned into
um the state custody
uh
they they never went to jail nothing
nothing happened
they we do go to court but they try to
get us back the system said no
um then my biological father comes in I
don't know how but he ended up coming
into the court
he was trying to get us back but the
judge said no because we've been already
here and we live here and whatnot
so
I'm going zigzag here I know this is
confusing but it's it was just so much
going on have you ever talked about this
before no not really my kids I I only
tell them enough
my husband knows a lot what happened
um my sister doesn't talk about it
because she gets angry she never forgave
my mother she never forgave my father
um
so she carried a lot of hate
me I was more like I I suppressed it I
kept putting it down like
like it didn't happen so anyways I we
were in the system and I was getting
bounced around from foster home so I
didn't have no
stability I didn't know what I didn't
know what was going on so then I started
uh rebelling
taking
[Music]
um
not going to school things like that and
then
that's when I met my first husband
and we were young very young
then uh we ended up having my first
child so I was 17 when this all happened
and then after that you know I started
my kids were two years apart I was still
with my husband and my first husband
um
that was rough too because we were both
young we didn't we didn't understand you
know we were kids raising kids but we
did the best we could and
it turned out great because they're all
great now but then it went into
um
me starting to like I was under I was
under a lot of like uh
I didn't understand I wanted to know I
wanted to reach out I wanted to figure
out why and where I was from who am I
you know they told me I was Filipino
then when I was 17 no 15 my biological
father was like no they told you that
you're tomorrow I'm like what the heck
is a Chamorro like I don't know what
that is
so he kind of like
told me and
um
he was like trying to tell me like uh
our culture things like that
and he does when he started coming back
into my life he somehow found me
um through White Pages
all right right
so he somehow found me he called the
operator the operator and he's in the
islands now so he's trying to find me
here in the states he knew I was in
Connecticut somewhere but
we he reached out we started um talking
and he was asking questions how this
that and I told him you know life was
hard but we're getting through
and my sister was going through a lot
she was she also was bouncing around she
was her kids for um my nieces and my
nephew
she was having them at a young age so we
we grew up extremely fast there was no
time to think about
what happened and and why this so we
just like went through life just you
know just going through without
really understanding did you did your
biological father understand
he he was very upset he was very angry
that the
that he did he trusted them
but
um he he pretty much like just gave a we
just talked and tried to get to know
each other through a phone instead of
like you know me going over there
so
I'll just go through that and then I'll
just skip all of you know because it's a
lot so I'll go to 33.
um me and my ex-husband we divorce our
kids
it was hard for them but you know they
knew what was kind of going on and they
were upset they were upset with me
really because I was the one that left
I left them I left their father that's
it was just crazy um
I did use drugs I didn't know at one
time I was doing cocaine and that was
like to suppress everything put me in a
good mood because I was like I just
didn't know how to handle I was so
stressed out I had four kids I got an
ex-husband that me and him are arguing
every single day so it was rough so I
did I started using cocaine and it felt
good and I felt like okay this is good I
could get rid of all the pain and
suffering that I think I'm doing so
so that happened for a few years
then I got a divorce and at the same
time that following year I met my
husband
and I think he was definitely an angel
that walked into my life because I
needed somebody to
hold me to listen to me because with my
first husband we I didn't talk to him
about anything
like I said we were just kids we really
didn't learn how to love we were more
like brother and sister if really
uh so my I started opening up with my
husband
and
once I started doing that
things started to come out of me like I
was starting to get angry just angry for
no reason I was happy I was sad I was
being manic I was drinking every day
I I was drinking to the point where I
would pass out because I wanted to pass
out I didn't want to I didn't want to
see anything I was just like living
you know everybody thought I was living
my my high life but I wasn't I was
actually suffering inside nobody really
nobody thought anything you know I was
like
always happy and and this and that but
that was just all of all the mask
because at the end of the day I was I
was suffering
so
I felt I started falling at depression
and I started
um realizing something wasn't right so I
got admitted to a hospital at one point
and I didn't take it seriously
um I was told I I have depression
bipolar and I didn't believe it because
again back then that wasn't talked about
no nobody really talked about mental
illness back then
um so
I wasn't taking my medication again I
was hiding it like I don't I don't need
this I don't have that I don't what is
this
so fast forward to a few years
um
I had a breakdown
a really bad breakdown
um it was like the worst thing that
could ever happen
um
I started getting
reunited with my biological mother and
that happened a few times I went over
there a few times and
spent time with her and uh tried to get
what I can out of her but she really
didn't talk about that wasn't she didn't
want to talk about it
so I left it alone and I just said you
know what it was her life it happened
for whatever reason and so I just let it
go I just said you know what I'm gonna
forgive her forgive her because there's
nothing I could do now
so I started forming a relationship with
her
and then like two years down the line
she passed which was
in February of 2018.
so I got the news I flew over there
and then I flew back and then
in May I'll say this from February to
May it was
I didn't know what I just didn't know
what I was feeling inside I was so
confused I was angry I didn't want to be
around anybody I didn't like my kids I
didn't like my husband I didn't like
anybody
so me and my husband we had separated
and I was at my daughter's house
and I remember saying that's it
I I don't need to be here anymore I
don't understand my life
I don't understand where I'm going
and I definitely don't understand why I
went through what I went through
so I did
the unthinkable I tried to take my life
I really did I really did
so uh
should I say what I did oh no sure okay
I took every medication I had that was
there
literally everything I didn't think
about it twice I didn't have a a view of
my kids in my head I didn't see my I
just like blacked out and I just took
everything not thinking of the damage I
would do with the with my family I
didn't think of anything so I took it
uh 14 hours later the next morning my
daughter found me
um I was in the room and my whole body
had fell onto my arm
so when my daughter found me I was like
dead like pretty much gone I can't
believe I even lasted 14 hours
so uh
my arm was like a football it was all
the blood literally
I stopped all the blood like I guess I
might my body weight
um so they rushed they called 9-1-1
I get to the hospital
and
my kids because my husband wasn't there
my kids had to make the decision if if
they could try to save the arm or
amputate the arm
and
um
I felt so bad when after I knew all this
that they had to make the this the dish
I can't even talk right now decision
because
I was I was pretty much like in a coma
like I didn't I did I was there I was on
the um what do you call it the
ventilator I was on all that all the
machines and they had to make the call
so they tried to save it which they told
the doctor to try to do as much as you
can to save it and see what happens
there because they had they had to make
the decision amputate it or save it so
they chose that which I'm grateful
um so when I woke up in the in the
hospital
I didn't know what was I I really didn't
know what was going on I didn't know
anything I was like why am I here
and I see my son I see my husband to the
side and I'm just so like what I'm in so
like La La Land I just don't know what's
going on
so that's when I woke up and I after I
came
started coming out of it I looked at my
arm I'm like why is my arm bandaged
and the nurse wouldn't say anything she
didn't say anything at first she was
like oh I'll go get the doctor
so a little while after the doctor came
and he realized that you know now he
realized but he just pretty much said
your arm is is no good like the damage
that you did the nerves everything we
could try to see if therapy helps in the
future blah blah blah so
how's your arm ah no it's there
but I can't I can't pick I can't close
my hand I can't
I try to do what I can with it but it's
pretty much like there's no nerves there
it's pretty much I've had multiple
um
surgeries I had a skin graft
from my thigh
got hurt to know what I did tomorrow so
every day is like a I have to see it and
I I just reminds me of every day like
wow I lived through that and I'm
grateful that I'm alive now
um
I went through intensive therapy
intensive I was like
seeing a therapist twice a week
every week
um and it helped it really did because I
didn't think I could come out of it
that's how depressed I was it was only
five years ago yeah
yeah 2018 yeah
yeah it's crazy
and then um I went through therapy and
everything was going well
and then
in
2021 I did it again
I went through I'm telling you it was an
up down thing with me on
one minute I was fine thinking I could
handle it I had therapy
um
I thought I was doing okay
and then in um
Thanksgiving of 2001 literally
Thanksgiving I I did it again
I tried to take it my life
and again
it's I think it's just everything inside
of me I just didn't know I still didn't
understand how come I wasn't uh
recovering I wasn't
feeling right you know why am I going
through this
I just got so depressed I did it again
and I hurt my family again
so that that again was like
embarrassing
I don't know if I should say that
because I actually
survived to see their reaction and I
know they they probably felt bad for me
but
deep down inside I felt so ashamed I
felt I I just felt like a coward that I
wasn't
I wasn't uh
talking or telling
and I think that was my promise because
I just never shared it I never wanted to
talk about it
um
and I had to go through therapy again
and it's a struggle
bipolar depression
that's what I got PTSD I got that too
have you been diagnosed yeah yeah
definitely uh I was uh diagnosed and
I was diagnosed before like in 2015 but
I didn't take it serious I wasn't taking
the medication but it was 2018 where I I
woke up and I said you know what
I gotta take this serious I guess I am
because I was going through the ups the
Downs the mood swings major mood swings
I cry happy sad all in like 10 minutes I
didn't understand that
but um
did you look at
these events that have happened in your
adult life as
the after effects of a childhood without
love yeah
I think that's what it is
we didn't have love
um we
we were told to be silent don't you
share your feelings don't you tell
what's in this house don't talk about
nothing so I grew up with that and I
never like really
I never really got out of that I just
kept caring that that thing in my head
like don't talk about it
you know it's you're it's nothing
dumb fall in your head type thing how
many children do you have I have four
you have four how are they they're great
they're doing really good so you're
doing a good job with them I did I gotta
say yeah I tried I really tried their
father too he's a good guy and he we
tried to
um do the best we could with them
um so you're breaking the cycle
yeah and it's still it's still going I
can't say it you know it's still every
day is a new day every day is a
different day every day
you know you just gotta think of the
that you survived it and you know it's
it's definitely like
gotta get that help
if you don't get that help you're
struggling and struggling for the rest
of your life until you do plus your
husband seems great yeah he is he's a
great support
um
he's been through both suicide attempts
and it was hard for him
and I felt so bad like I can't believe I
did this to him my kids my whole family
and uh
so now we uh
we try to help others with it's it
because that's all we could do we could
just try to help and the little bit that
we do we feel like you know
impact with somebody somehow
um it probably helps you as well yeah
yeah
and even though I don't share my story I
try to like
help them or whoever it may be
a child who grows up without love is
gonna have a whole series of yeah there
was a lot of events and yeah
yeah it was definitely chaos uh
so now through it all
I'm still getting my I still get my
therapy I am on the right medication now
that was a that was just a whole nother
thing because you got to find the right
thing to help you everybody yeah therapy
definitely
if I didn't have that then I'd probably
be in a bad spot again to keep these to
keep these things secret yeah it's got
to be just poisonous it is it really is
and I feel bad because like my sister
she goes through it but she's she's
worse than me she really doesn't like
she the the talk of it makes her angry
you know just if I even make like a
comment she gets very angry and I don't
and I don't want to get her angry
but she sees her view I see mine
um
we kind of like uh stop talking I don't
know why we just started drifting off
my other siblings uh I have one in
Seattle
we don't talk that much either
so none of them we're kind of like all
you guys all deal with it differently
yeah we do we do
and
yeah so
it's the help like you know you got to
get the help and if you don't get it
like you you're just all that struggle
and
I just feel bad because
I should have got the help earlier I
mean when you were a child and you're
going through this crazy
sexual abuse from your adopted father
and the verbal physical yeah yeah so did
Mom were you were you and your sister
just like
um or were you just kids that didn't
know anything we were kids and we like I
said we we started figuring out things
weren't right you know
birthdays holidays you know just
um we would go to fancy parties and
we weren't we weren't allowed to
interact we we just stand there look
pretty where where this fancy little
dress where were you little ruffled
socks you know just stand there and
that's what me and my sister did we
weren't we didn't go play we just sat
there around the table with the adults
so they could get all this credit like
yeah I adopted these kids
and we weren't we were just like I don't
know
we just we were just kids but it didn't
turn you into a dark evil person no no
thank god
um
yeah so it was they adopted us for all
the wrong reasons and we and we just
happened to be the kids that happened to
be the ones that went through it with
them
she's to lock Us in the basement that
was another thing she loved doing that
um if we uh
if we didn't do what we were told
she'd throw things at me like I have
cuts on my on my
foot she had to throw a plate at me just
like that just you didn't do this bam
and
that's how she was
and she she I think she was angry
because of what her husband was doing I
think that's why she was taking all that
anger out
on me and then my sister she you know
she would just do it she was just awful
awful if any of those behaviors been
things that you've picked up with your
children
silence don't talk
the physical what your adopted parents
did to you no no no no like towards my
kids yeah no no no no no no so how do
you how to learn to treat your kids
differently when you come from crap
I just
I wanted to give them something I didn't
have which was love and
I didn't I wasn't very affectionate to
my kids but I definitely will I would
always say you know I love you you know
me or do good in school but I just I
really didn't embrace them when they
were kids I tried everyone has different
styles yeah three different ways of
showing love yeah so I was very
protective of my girls you know
don't talk to this I did the whole talk
with them and always watched and
made sure they were okay
but I think I did okay in life and I'm
still going through day by day every day
you know what would you say is the most
important lesson you've learned from
this
don't put a Band-Aid on it
heal the cut
heal it Stitch it heal it
let it dry up I mean that's what I'm
going through I'm trying to pick that
Band-Aid up
because
the more it says it's gonna get infected
right so that's what happened with me
I got so infected I blew up I just
didn't know what to do with my life
but um I'm stable that's a good thing
you're on medication now oh yeah
your presence yes yes
um
and I'm I'm in a better place now
and
look I said I still get therapy
I I need that
I believe people should get that because
it helps everybody could use it yeah
yeah
um
and then my husband he's he's also my
you know he's my therapist
if I feel
if I feel like uh I'm overwhelmed or I
have this super anxiety I have crazy
nightmares he's always trying to shake
me because he tells me I talk in my
sleep I jump I sweat
it's a lot of nightmares
um because there's so much more in the
CH in my childhood but I'm it's you know
I mean they should be teaching these
skills in yeah in high school rather
than trigonometry and things but you
think about it back then
there was no such thing as depression
what no but as a partner as a wife
husband whatever
you're almost that's part of the part of
the job is being a therapist yeah yeah
to understand what they're going through
even if they're not explaining it not
talking about it yeah yeah
and it's funny because he he suffers
bipolar
and it's uh we're both like for each
other's crutch you know we help each
other out
when he's down and I'm down we're like
we try so hard to
um to encourage one another and
give that support and love and
and just like you know
just be there because you need somebody
to talk to
you know you can't hold it all down
that's what I did
and um
that's about it
all right Michelle thank you so much for
sharing your story thank you
I hope so too thank you